hey what is up guys mkbhd here from the
crispiest lens out there to customizing
a little bit of color where you never
really could this is dope tech number
two all right so in dope tech number one
i actually started talking about some of
the equipment i used to make all these
videos starting with the camera the red
weapon dragon but i didn't talk about
the lens on it that is the sigma 18-35 f
1.8 and it is probably my favorite piece
of tech that i own now i have primes and
everything and you can never really
quite match the sharpness and the image
quality from a prime lens with a zoom
but this is a one-of-a-kind lens and it
gets the closest that i've ever seen the
build quality is top-notch much like the
rest of the sigma art series and it
combines a set of specs that you
literally do not see in any other zoom
lens so the 18 to 35 millimeter zoom
which is nice and wide to mid
then the constant super fast f 1.8
aperture throughout the whole zoom range
and a really close minimum focus
distance of just 11 inches from the base
of the lens so you can get really close
to pull off some basically macro shots
with this lens so that and the image you
get out of it is super sharp from edge
to edge if you want any test footage
i've been using it i'd say probably
about 75 of the shots in my last 50
videos went through this glass so when
people ask about equipment it's pretty
easily the number one lens i recommend
there's a canon version a nikon version
all types the one downside being it's
for crop sensors only i'm definitely
going to miss it when i switch to a full
frame camera in a few months but if
you're shooting aps-c or super 35 or
pretty much anything that's not full
frame and you have a budget for it
do it team crispy welcomes you all right
so custom tech is pretty dope and i'm
sure you guys already know that along
with pixels and dynamic range red and
black is one of my favorite combos and i
like to see that in tech when i can some
of you might remember the mkbhd edition
13-inch retina macbook pro painted and
logo replaced by colorware last year so
a year and a half later it still looks
pretty great the paint has held up fine
so that's good news but the laptop
itself is a little dated and i'm looking
for it to be a mobile editing rig so
i sent in a new fully loaded 50-inch
retina macbook pro
with the same treatment of that stealth
matte black kept the red hinge
and i am now a very happy mobile editor
plus they are now able to paint the
trackpad too so no more silver trackpad
sticking out like a sore thumb this
thing is freaking beautiful and
colorware if you didn't know does this
with all types of devices laptops the
imac smartphones accessories i think
they'll have it for the new apple
keyboard and magic mouse pretty soon and
my personal favorite the mkbhd
headphones of choice custom sennheiser
hd800 now this is what a normal pair of
hd 800s looks like silver and black i've
shown these in a previous video pretty
classy but you can pick all the colors
you would want of all the different
parts the hinge the grille and
everything on colorware site so this is
what i picked and then this is what it
looks like in real life pretty clean
obviously if you're a fan of red and
black like me this is going to look hot
if not i'm sure you can find your own
colors to suit your setup as for those
curious i have this going into a woo
audio wa7 firefly right now along with a
pair of yamaha studio monitors anyway
colorware is dope and everything but
it's just not cheap
and it's also not fast it takes
something like two weeks for them to
accept your shipment take it apart paint
it and ship it back plus it does void
your manufacturer warranty usually
though they do provide their own but i
wouldn't expect to take this into the
apple store to get anything fixed so a
less permanent less expensive version of
the colorward treatment would be a skin
essentially a vinyl sticker over the top
of your device the upside to a skin is
that it is temporary and it is much
cheaper than a custom paint job kind of
like a car getting a wrap versus new
paint and you can change the texture if
you want the only real downside being
precision or how study your hand is the
skin from dbrand you're looking at here
they're all precisely cut but it's
really all about the application process
too and getting that right so they cover
almost all the same devices that
colorware does from smartphones right up
to laptops and consoles and they will be
precisely cut so it's just a matter of
you getting it right and it'll look as
good as you make it anyway that's it for
dope tech number two it's a brand new
series so definitely leave your
suggestions in the comments below for
more stuff you want to see in between
all these reviews and i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace